when tip first came to this group I
didn't know who the [ __ ] she was
multiple times because I didn't know how
long she was gonna last and I didn't
want to commit myself to somebody only
to have him leave yeah so when you first
came around I was just gonna let the
group fill you out first and then I
would just kind of like okay she's gonna
stick around so let me invest some time
into her because at that point it was I
didn't know if you were gonna stick
around and yeah me neither
yeah and TIFF was hard to become a
catch-22 though cuz it's like everyone's
kind of like well is she even gonna be
here is it worth our time but then it
like makes it harder yeah and then for
me too because I had the same feeling
towards other people I'm like well
should I even bother getting close to
David and bard and Gio and TIFF and all
these people if I'm just gonna leave
anyways you know so it was like it was
you guys moved in together and you were
living and when I kind of figured all
you're they're living together and [ __ ]
you know I didn't because I didn't know
that off the bat either yeah so I was
like oh you know and then and it's also
weird too I think because like I feel
like if maybe if I was a girl it'd be a
lot easier right no really you don't
think so no she makes friends with guys
like that really fast I like women it's
just a lot more complicated yeah and it
takes a lot longer yeah to be like hella
close she got I think closer with you
and Steve way quicker than any of the
girls but that's the that's true with a
lot of the girls you know like my girls
are very unique yeah they're they're not
very girly in that traditional sense of
where like girls [ __ ] rule a lot of
the girls in this group are very partner
connected so they hang out with their
partner and then if the partner hangs
out with somebody else then they'll do
it together right so I saw something
that I'm not really used to I think
that's the difference between me and I
think majority the JK people was that
Mariel has her own set of friends and I
had my own set of friends yeah y'all's
relationship is totally different yeah
compared to all of us yeah
and so I think but that's the part that
was a little not odd for me just because
when we had to make sure that we were
having friend time it was it was a
little more difficult cuz my doors are
always open like I always tell people
like you want to hang out come and hang
out like with Khalifa or whatever he
texted me I'm like come on over let's
let's do something I just let Mariel
know I go hey Khalifa wants to hang out
today I'm gonna I'm gonna bounce is that
cool she goes I don't have to ask her I
just told her it's gonna happen yeah but
you know I think because everything once
again it was so we were so tied to our
old memories we don't need to do that no
it's like I could not
see him for three years I'll pick it up
right where it left off yeah like
nothing ever happened
but for you you were a new person you
didn't have that rapport so it was a lot
more difficult and you know he was it
was true we used to have barbecues all
the [ __ ] all the time we played
basketball together and you we all suck
no we played like three three four times
a week we had these like great moments
where we connected and bonded on a level
level that most people don't do in such
a short amount of time and I think you
didn't get to experience that yeah and
then we would be fighting over stuff
that because we were shocked that our
expectations weren't meeting reality so
we were fighting behind the scenes and
then I come eat dinner with all y'all
and I'm already like wow [ __ ] this whole
[Laughter]
what the hell's wrong with ya and I was
like she's invited me and I'm like man
it's so weird like why don't you like my
friends yeah that's weird cuz I like I
liked everyone I saw everyone on YouTube
before I met them and I was like all
these people seem cool like geo seem
cool or whatever but then matter and
person I was like ah so I can say that a
lot in public but yeah yeah that's so
interesting because people don't know
like this perspective behind just what
they see on the screen like even for you
you feel victim to that you know I think
hopefully I'm almost the exact same
person I'm on screen maybe just a lot I
think you're better and realize that you
are on screen honestly I like hanging
out with you but then at some of these
other people in the group at the
beginning I was like god I wish I just
never met them because I liked them on
video and that was it it's really
because um I don't know maybe it's
because like like I said like I've
always been the type of person in the
group and even Mariel notices about me
she always mentions it she goes people
warm up to you fast you know he that
people hate me or they really it depends
if I like that you know so she goes when
you like somebody she goes they could
sense how much you like them yeah you
know you dislike them the whole universe
feels it yeah like it's like boom like
you completely just shut them out like
they don't exist like she's even seen me
like some people what's up I go
nice like walk past them cuz I don't
wanna say anything mean yeah you know
you're very strong emotionally yeah yeah
it's just like I just um I think it's
because you know when you get burned
when you're younger I just don't like to
waste time with people anymore it's if I
like you I'm not afraid to express how
much I like you if I respect you
I'm not afraid to express how much I
respect you and I'll just leave it at
that why even hide it at this point but
once again the other side is if I
[ __ ] dislike you the you will [ __ ]
feel it you know I'm not gonna go I'm
gonna call you an [ __ ] but you could
tell when a spotting it everybody you
say something me I don't laugh at one
that once deals like that - yeah that's
probably what it is geo and I actually
had this thing where it's funny cuz we
dislike the same people and then we just
I'll just look at her she goes yup I'm
like yep I already know what you're
saying I [ __ ] hate that person yeah
y'all are like smizing to each other
across the room well I'm sitting there
as a new girlfriend - Joe - oh my
comment [ __ ] ELISA so let's see them
smizing to each other how about you
you're fine now I am I think like I did
I never felt any bad way towards you
though like I didn't think that there
was anything cuz once again I never
spent as much time with you because I'm
I'm JK honorary member I still got my
own thing yeah and then I would come
into the mix after and then you know I
what hear you speak about what you're
going through and then the group would
talk about how things just aren't
messing well and then I start picking up
pieces a little bit and I'm like yeah I
can see like how our attitude can be bad
and I talk to you and I could see how
you think there'd being this way - so it
all kind of made sense and it's just
like I said you were thrown into
something that was very hard for you to
meld it yeah it was not a good idea but
I did it and I think it made me stronger
and now I feel like I could be thrown
into a lot more situations with a better
idea of how to handle myself so it was
worth it I guess yeah you needed it yeah
just the way I needed you to make me
angry he actually I think out of all the
JK people changed the most in the past
like just seven or eight years like the
first time I've seen him till now he's
but he's he's actually like a 180 mm-hmm
like number one emotionally on like
emotionally an empathy are the two
things that I think that you've changed
the most empathy is something that
you've gained
maybe not to like the normal standard
but like you do and you do and you do
have it you do have a lot of empathy and
you also understand how to assess a
situation from a less emotional state
because I think like when you were first
you were such an excitable human being
that everything was just Spartan man I
was telling my I forgot who else on the
other day but I I don't I used to live
life without thinking mmm everything's
just feeling yeah and I don't even
remember a lot of things that I did yeah
I'm just living in the moment yeah and I
thought a lot but about things that
didn't matter it was not internal it was
about politics [ __ ] philosophy
whatever I'm reading [ __ ] right yeah and
I'm just going down the rabbit hole of
information but I'm just a constant
impulse yeah so I I was ruled by my
feelings man I just did whatever the
[ __ ] I wanted yeah and I don't know I
think there's good in in that where I
got to where I am today cuz I'm not
thinking and I'm not living by my fear
or anything I just do it but also if I
don't self reflect I don't grow you know
and if I'm not aware of the situation
it's like I'm just living in a [ __ ]
dream right but I mean I'm not taking
into considerations of what what's going
on the dynamic yeah so that's kind of
like oh [ __ ] I had to figure that out
because it especially with her I'm like
oh my reality is not her reality yeah
how do you feel like you've changed a
lot yes as you moved here I think I may
be more conscious of how I'm coming
across like even though I still have
like kind of [ __ ] face a lot and I
complain a lot I I'm a hundred percent
more aware of like how I'm projecting
myself and my energy into a room that
was a big thing because use it I used to
be the same way like I wasn't really
thinking about like how my energy was
spilling out into the world around me
and now I'm obviously there's cameras on
me and there's people telling me things
about myself and there's comments so
like I'm more a little bit more aware of
that hmm
but emotionally I don't know if I've
changed that much emotionally I think
I'm about the same really yeah do you I
mean I guess like for me I guess from
like an outside perspective I think like
maybe you don't see it but I see it is
more like I think you're more honest
with yourself because having having that
ability to say like okay people do see
me a certain way even though that I
don't feel it is some you learning how
to be honest with yourself yeah it's
like oh maybe I don't really know myself
as well as I thought I did yeah so
that's that's a huge thing I think
that's some [ __ ] that I struggle with
all the [ __ ] time like I said I don't
know I was [ __ ] fat like I know
people he's a joke I didn't know cuz I
would see myself in the mirror and I'm
like I still got these bits she's like
what about them here but this is the
problem you know what guys know how to
compartment like really well yeah we're
just like mmm that nipple looks nice and
circular know how to see the beauty in
[ __ ] garbage yeah I know how to see
the garbage and beauty listening to this
[ __ ] like on the way here and it was
about controlling your outlook on life
and negative emotions right and they're
saying how Mother Teresa she would like
go down India and she's like she sees
all these dead [ __ ] bodies right he's
like people sick people banging she sees
all this [ __ ] right and then she sees a
piece of [ __ ] on the floor and out of
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
there's a flower growing out of it that
was her that was her pivotal moment when
that moment was when she was like oh I'm
able to like see the beauty in all of
this disaster yeah what other good is
there in the world
oh wow and then so I'm like that's
either so [ __ ] optimistic to the
point where your delusional [ __ ] or
that's some that's a skill like to be
able to do that when skill do you
because I mean people are getting shot
up and dying around you and you're still
like there's something beautiful about
this you know or something good that
still exists in the world that's
something that's like I wish I had that
power I don't have that power I just
more like give in to the [ __ ] I might
get my car exploded today like it's so
bad like even the other day I got hit
I got rear-ended like going to the
[ __ ] sit meeting and I was just like
all right let it go because it was like
a scratch of the dead and I was like
Mike it's a Honda Element and the guy
looked at me who just goes he goes I'll
pay for a sight for what yeah why bother
dudes I fight it yeah just go away kind
of that's kind of reminding me of this
thing so this book I'm reading it's
called everything is [ __ ] by Mark
Manson and he talks about this concept
of a more fatty it's like a Frederick
Nietzsche thing that he came up with
it's like the love of one's fate so like
you're just kind of like going through
life just like septons yeah it's I
haven't fully grasped it concept of it
but it's a really interesting thing like
that and I think a lot of people should
kind of look it up and read into it but
it's just like the love of your fate
it's like your if it's good or if it's
bad or whatever it's like you're
accepting all of it because all of it is
life so if you can't run from getting
hit in the car like you know you can't
run running family death you can't run
from hurt you can't run from a lot of
pain right and in that same pump you
listening to they were saying like okay
so these things is just a part of life
but the more you try to fight it and
deny it the bigger it becomes I mean you
gotta just experience it that's just so
[ __ ] you just gotta go through with it
but then not have a judgement on it when
you start judging it is when it starts
becoming this thing where you obsess
about it and I [ __ ] like that I've
been I mean I guess I feel like I invoke
something like that too just not in as
like xvi is that but that's you know we
talk about all the time you know that's
[ __ ] life it's just life why are you
[ __ ] so I don't know you know yeah we
talk about people who wallow in their
own sadness because something bad
happens it will prolong it yeah that's
been me for most of my life have been
very nihilistic person and that's why I
have that kind of dark energy and that's
I guess if we're gonna say how I've
changed the most and how you're saying
being honest with yourself that's how
I'm being more honest with myself and
like recognizing recognizing that I
carry a dark cloud and I'm just like all
everything sucks and I'm like you know
I'm like in a black-and-white vintage
film with a cigarette like you know like
we just pick it right now the [ __ ]
cigarette the long cigarette some sad
ass music did you get what songs so damn
happy you should have got with a goth
guy or some [ __ ] I know I should get
pale ass rocker we would have gotten
along a lot better problem I know you
two could have sat in the corner talk
[ __ ] all day yeah I literally just
picked you with that long cigarette and
this [ __ ] dudes just walking one so
what are you doing there pretty late in
the world spinning yeah I mean do you
feel like I mean what do you think you
know like that though I mean that's a
Jedi know why she's like I mean I guess
just the abandonment that I have faced
as a child just made me like sad and
feel like there's you know life sucks
and all that and I just never grew out
of it so I think that's a I haven't
reached level of maturity to grow out of
that like adolescent what you
accomplished so I mean let's let's move
off she does JK like these